for wednesday february 16 2022
58 event a
special meeting called by mayor watson
to discuss matters related to the
ongoing impacts of the trump conqueror
demonstration and illegal occupation of
the city's residences and businesses
by electronic participation this meeting
will be held through electronic
participation according to section 238
of the municipal act 2001
as amended by the copen 19 economic
recovery act
those who are able to please rise for a
moment of personal reflection
[Music]
thank you merci
um roll call please madam clerk
counselor luloff
president
councillor dudas
i'm here
councilor harder here
councillor curry
here
council shantiri madison
councillor gower
here
councillor kavanaugh
here
council shirley
councillor egler
your
counselor deans
i'm here
counselor tierney
flurry you see
counselor king here
counselor mckenny
president
counselor leeper
here
councillor brockington
here
councilor menard
here
conseclucci
i'm here counselor hubley
here
mayor watson
you see
you have a quorum mr mayor thank you um
resolving no regrets filed to date
resolving into committee the whole
councilor clutier please signed by
councillor kitts
councilor gloucester
sorry about that that city council
resolved to move into committee the
whole pursuant to section 52 of the
procedure by law
carried i have a question mayor on that
and the question is whether we can have
a different chair for today given the
nature of the discussion we're going to
be going through i think a more neutral
chair would be appropriate
uh no i disagree with that i chair the
council meeting so we're going to
continue on okay i'll put a motion
forward to have counselor dudas chair
the meeting of deputy mayor
just given
the
need for neutrality today
and the normal undemocratic way that
meetings are run
and do you have a second or for the
motion
i'll second council leaper
okay yays and nays and councilor
menard's motion
counselor curry
no
counselor dudas
[Music]
no
counselor mckinney
yes
councilor moffitt
no
counselor kavanagh
yes
councilor king
yes
counselor gower
no
counselor meehan
yes
councillor deruss
no
jon secrucci no
cancer deans
yes
no counselor kids
no
counselor el shantiri
no
counselor hubley
no
counselor leaper
yes
counselor harder
no
counselor tierney
no
counselor brockington
yes
counselor shirelli
councillor menard
yes
councillor luloff
no
counselor eggley
mayor watson
no
eight years 15 nice thank you
yeah a motion to go into committee of
the whole carried update
we're meeting today to discuss the
ongoing occupation of our city which is
currently in its third week
i recognize how difficult this has been
on our residents business owners and
their workers especially in the downtown
core
residents are exhausted and terrified
and our small businesses are struggling
to keep staff attract customers and to
stay open
on february 6 given the severity of the
situation i declared a state of
emergency in the city of ottawa at a
time when the occupation was entering
its second week
and as residents all around us were
begging us to act to protect their
neighborhoods they felt abandoned by all
levels of government frankly they had
endured two weeks of inaction and finger
pointing
they feel abandoned by their government
reached out last week to try to broker a
short-term solution between the city and
some of the convoy organizers i saw an
opportunity to work in good faith to
secure some relief for our downtown
residents
thankfully starting monday afternoon we
saw progress when trucks cleared out of
major streets like o'connor and bank and
into available space on wellington
43 large trucks left the residential
districts of centertown on monday and
this has already provided approximately
15 000 residents with a heightened sense
of security and a reprieve from the
constant noise and exhaust fumes
affecting them in their neighborhood
there's been more progress since monday
and that was uh and what was 150 tractor
trailers just a few days ago have now
been reduced by half
putting more vehicles on wellington to
offer our residents a reprieve from the
daily siege is an easy decision to take
unless you value buildings over the
sanity of our residents to date the
convoy organizers have kept their word
by getting a significant number of
trucks to move out from residential
streets not all of them unfortunately
that they don't control into a smaller
and more manageable perimeter along
wellington on friday premier ford
declared a state of emergency in the
province of ontario and the next day
enacted various stronger tools to assist
our police and by-law officers in
cracking down on illegal activity
on monday prime minister trudeau's
government invoked the federal
emergencies act which provides even more
additional leverage to put an end to
this occupation
these measures target the international
funds that and assets sustaining the
movement
it will also compel service providers
like towing companies to respond to the
city's call for help or face massive
fines
i want to thank our federal provincial
partners for their help in delivering
these tools and i have no doubt that
these will help us in our efforts to end
this occupation
this will help us put an end to this
occupation and i thank the province and
the federal government for their
assistance
i'm pleased that our advocacy for more
police officers has started to
materialize
we need the support of both our federal
and provincial governments in order to
back up our police officers and to
enforce the full scope of the law
and of these new measures i'm encouraged
by the recent policing developments
including the fact that both the rcmp
and the opp have named command leaders
to help end the occupation in our city i
know that members of council the general
public and partner agencies who know him
and have dealt with him are pleased to
see steve bell assume command acting
command of our municipal police force
i've been very i have been having
encouraging discussions with federal
ministers who are very much committed to
helping us
also convey to both the prime minister
and the premier how dire the situation
is for our downtown businesses who are
already struggling to stay afloat due to
the pandemic i've asked them to put in
place the supports that business owners
and their employees need to survive this
crisis and just to simply pay their rent
the devoid day no santa please
i said situation
i was encouraged to hear prime minister
trudeau mentioned on monday that
announcement to this effect would take
place in the coming days
i'll continue to work with our federal
provincial partners until we see a
robust assistance program and package
that our cities businesses and workers
need to make it through this crisis this
past weekend some residents joined
peaceful counter-demonstrations where
they confront a protester
protesters i congratulate them i know
we're all tired and upset but we will
get through this and our city will
return to the place we know and love
although i understand their anger and
their frustration the situation remains
volatile and i want to emphasize that we
are trying to keep everyone safe the
ottawa police service is leading nearly
190 criminal active criminal
investigations including 15 related to
hate motivated incidents and since the
occupation began ops officers have
arrested 33 individuals for criminal
behavior and 18 have received charges
for a litany of unlawful acts compare
committed in our city our bile officers
are also hard at work enforcing our
city's bylaws and maintaining emergency
access in the red zone on sunday alone
they issued 366 parking infractions and
since january 28th they have issued a
total of
2922 parking tickets in the red zone
on monday the city was granted an
injunction by the ontario superior court
which will help our police and bylaw
officers crack down on illegal fires
fireworks noise and idling going forward
i want to remind our residents that any
hate motivated incidents and any
criminal offenses directly related to
the demonstrations can be reported to
the ottawa police at ottawa police dot
ca
all reports will be pursued to the full
extent of the law
i know ops city councillors and city
staff are working tirelessly and i want
to thank you for your service i also
want to acknowledge that this occupation
has taken a severe toll on our front
line workers including in our grocery
stores pharmacies restaurants and hotels
as well as the dedicated health care
providers in our community
many are facing hardships just trying to
get safety to work work or trying to
help someone some of the most vulnerable
people in our community i want to
acknowledge that throughout these events
many health and social service providers
across ottawa have not wavered in
providing critical services to our
residents for example i know that
monique and her formidable team at the
good companion center have gone out of
their way to identify and reach out to
seniors who have been stuck at home
throughout this terrible ordeal
and for these seniors and all those who
don't feel safe leaving their homes this
is taking a real toll on their mental
health as well
it can be hard to reach out for help but
there are services and people who can in
fact help you if you need to speak to
someone you can start by calling the
distress center of ottawa support line
at 613-238-3311
613-641-6433
to our elected officials and our
residents i urge patience patience and
solidarity while we get through this
i have a simple message the window of
opportunity for you to leave our city is
closing
the combined ops opp and rcmp presence
is growing stronger every day and many
of you are probably longing to get back
to your own communities
if you leave now voluntarily the odds of
being able to leave without your prop
with your property are quite high
it's my understanding that those who
want to leave now will be allowed to
leave unless they have committed
criminal acts to those who never
intended to harm innocent residents in
our residential districts i urge you to
reflect on the serious consequences of
your continued occupation of our city
the longer you stay the greater the risk
to yourself and others
at the outset we all thought that this
would be a peaceful protest and that a
free that and that's a freedom we all
cherish in this country but this is no
longer that case and i ask you to go
back to your own communities and allow
our residents to reclaim their
neighborhoods their parks and their
regular daily lives free of harassment
and economic hardship
i now call on acting chief of police
steve bell to provide counsel with a
high level overview of how the situation
is unfolding in ottawa then we'll go to
our city manager steve cadillacques and
the gm of emergency and protective
services kim ayotte we'll also be joined
by city solicitor david white to answer
questions regarding the injunction as
well as prime minister's statement on
monday so
mr uh chief acting chief bell has one
hour so i'd urge members to please share
the time because he has an important
meeting with other
heads of police agencies at that time
acting chief bell please
thank you mr mayor and members of
council we're here today to provide you
a briefing on the plan of action that
has already begun to end this unlawful
protest protest in our city we're also
here to answer questions from members of
council
this morning the command of the ontario
provincial police the royal canadian
mounted police and the ottawa police
service were briefed on the significant
steps being taken to bring a safe end to
this crisis
the ottawa police remains the police of
jurisdiction and the lead of this
intimate integrated command
this is the city we're sworn to protect
it's our responsibility and our job to
safely remove this unlawful protest
the rcmp and the opp are here to support
us and i thank them for the significant
efforts and resources that they are
bringing forward
we have a methodical and well-resourced
plan with a simple mission we're going
to take back the entirety of the
downtown core and every occupied space
we're going to remove this unlawful
protest we will return our city to a
state of normalcy
over the last few days we've developed
strategies to deal with all possible
scenarios
we will be focused on public safety
demonstrator safety and officer safety
all of our plans and actions will be
lawful and in line with the charter
demonstrators must leave the unlawful
protest sites officers are already going
truck to truck to advise them of this
demand
we want them to do this peacefully and
immediately and we're facilitating the
departure of anyone who wants to leave
we also have appropriate and lawful
methods to remove anyone who refuses
we also are aware the children are in
the area this concerns us greatly
we've been engaged a planning team with
the children's aid society to encourage
anyone with children in the area to
leave and bring those children to a
place of safety we also have a plan to
ensure children are protected and cared
for during any actions
you'll be hearing and seeing these
actions in the coming days it will take
time to do this right every step will be
considered and methodical i ask for your
patience and confidence some of the
techniques we are lawfully able and
prepared to use are not what we're used
to seeing in ottawa but we are prepared
to use them and whatever means necessary
to bring about the safest outcome and
restore order
i'm confident that we now have the
resources the plan and the commitment to
get this job done
the plan will not be considered complete
until such a time as the streets are
cleared fully
we have commitment from our partners the
resources will remain in place until
this objective is achieved
the residents and businesses of our
downtown core and across the city have
suffered greatly we know that and we
regret the pain stress and disruption
this unlawful protest has caused
we know that this is left to tarnish
left our residents feeling unsafe and
abandoned and has tarnished our
reputation and out of our city we cannot
change the past but we can promise you
that we stand with you we will safely
return these areas to their normal state
as soon as we can
there are many questions being asked
about how we got here we all know that
there will be a full review and we all
welcome it so we can learn from the
events of the last three weeks
but for today and the days to come the
ottawa police service and our partners
are focused on getting this job done
whatever wherever these questions take
us i want you to know that the members
of the ottawa police service care
greatly about the city they are
committed to these actions and they are
ready to go i am proud of them and all
that they have done and all they will be
doing in the coming days thank you
okay so uh thank you very much acting
chief questions to the chief
uh councillor leeper please
thank you very much chief um
in the the past couple of weeks we've
heard a tough language from the police
there were press releases issued that
indicated that
occupiers should leave
and and that was not backed up with
enforcement
what has changed
um and i i guess bluntly why should
residents of ottawa believe police this
time
so
as i indicated in my statement we've
been continually working with our
partners over the past number of weeks
to build a comprehensive plan to
actually remove the demonstrators from
the streets of ottawa
we know that through the efforts of the
this council and the ottawa police
services board the call has gone out to
our partners to bring forward resources
to assist us in that as i indicated we
now have the plan and the resources and
the commitment to actually move ahead to
remove people from our streets our
desire will always be to successfully
negotiate and encourage people to leave
but in the absence of that we do have
the ability to remove them and now have
the plan and the resources to be able to
achieve that
shift what are the what are the
techniques to which you referred that
ottawa residents may not be used to
seeing
so it's it's too early to say and i
won't be able to provide any operational
um operational information so that we
can make sure that we do protect that
operation we we do have all of our
authorities and all of our abilities
around escalating use of force to be
able to remove people if they don't
comply but i'll again say our hope is as
we
look to the coming days people will see
our determination and we'll choose to
leave our streets if they choose not to
we do have the ability to have them
removed
chief i'm trying to understand why it
has taken nearly three weeks to develop
a plan for removing these folks the um
you know
it doesn't take that long surely to plan
for the removal of a hot tub in front of
the shadow laurier
i uh guess i'm i'm asking for some
reassurance or i'm asking for some
understanding of of why that plan is not
in place yet and and why residents
should believe that after three weeks we
finally have a plan and why that wasn't
in place within three or four days
so
like as we've indicated from the very
early days from even before this uh
demonstration started before it evolved
across the country as the freedom convoy
this is an unprecedented unparalleled
action within a within canada and
actually across north america as we've
gone through this we've identified the
challenges with with the location
that the trucks are in with the size and
complexity of mounting an operation to
actually take an area and have people
and equipment like exists removed
it has taken us time to do this
comprehensive level of planning that we
knew we need to do to be able to keep
our citizens safe the demonstrators safe
and our officers safe as we mount that
it also takes time to actually amass the
number of resources that we need to be
able to successfully take on an
operation like this we called in early
days to identify that there was
challenges with our resourcing levels
we've now seen an unparalleled level of
cooperation with our partners to be able
to bring in resources to assist us in
successfully ending this
i i know my colleagues are going to ask
more questions about those resources etc
but can i just ask to what degree are
you seeking guidance from the mayor in
terms of implementing any plans
so
not at all
the police is and the police are an
independent group that report through
the police services board who have opera
oversight on us as an organization so we
don't seek input from any level of
politics to actually have input on the
plans we're developing or delivering we
are very uh conscious of that cautious
of that and it's it's something that
goes with our professional oath to be
independent from the politics that may
exist but has the mayor had an
opportunity to be briefed on plans and
and an opportunity to weigh in on
whether those are advisable or not
so both the police service board chair
and the mayor were briefed early at a
very high level on the plans as is
allowed for us under the police services
act
we will continue to brief
members as necessary moving ahead
including a full in-camera operational
briefing to our police services board
okay um i will uh see the uh see the
time thank you
thank you councillor councillor hubley
please
thank you very much mr mayor and welcome
interim chief or acting chief whatever
the proper term is that we're supposed
to use
i want to ask if i'm hearing correctly
that you feel that you have enough
resources now
to get the job done that the people in
ottawa residents have been
asking to be done for weeks
so thanks for the question um
interim chief bell is is the title right
now um so what i can indicate is our
partners as i said have been extremely
cooperative and helpful to us in
allowing us to amass the resources that
we do require to mount such an operation
we are continuing to build that capacity
we're continuing to work with our
partners to make sure before we entered
into any sort of um direct action that
we would have the resources necessary in
order to be able to do that there are
steps and stages that we will go through
before we do enter in to any sort of
direct action and i'll again say our our
absolute uh hope and desire is that the
protesters understand that this protest
and demonstration is now coming to an
end and they willfully leave our streets
on their own accord
okay i i'm not gonna ask too many more
questions because i think a number of my
colleagues want to ask and i i want to
see you out there with the men and women
of the the ottawa police service to get
this done so i just want to leave if i
may mr mayor what one comment and that
is if the interim chief could make sure
the word gets to his the men and women
of the ottawa police service that we
appreciate what they're trying to do
here
we've got their back as you initiate
whatever actions that are coming in in
the next few days and appreciate you
stepping up to
take the lead on this
interim chief thank you mayor
thank you councillor uh councillor
cavanaugh please
okay thank you i thought others had
their hands out first but they'll take
it thank you
um
thank you very much uh chief uh for
for being here and giving us this report
uh one of the concerns right from the
beginning was that
lives could be at risk in terms of
moving too fast
and to interfering with the activities
that are going on
how can you explain how this has changed
um so i wouldn't explain that that it
has changed we we are always concerned
um about
intervening in any level with any sort
of protest with the risk of
demonstrators being injured members of
our public being injured or members
of our police services being injured we
continually
weigh that those risks and look at
proper interdiction techniques to
minimize those risks but i think it's
important to note those risks always
exist
if we have to actively dismantle
an ongoing protest so we have plans in
place we have resources available to
look at how we minimize those and we
will continue to work with
groups that are involved in the
demonstration to encourage
and have them leave on their own accord
before we do need to
intervene i'm particularly concerned
about the children and uh
and and how that will be dealt with is
this removing the children first it is
because clearly from what i saw this
morning there was resistance um that
these are people that have
hunkered down after 20 days and feel
empowered
and i i am concerned about that i know
the children's aid is involved this is a
matter of removing children first
so i share your concern counselor
kavanagh i'm i'm very concerned about
the children
and others that are in the in the
protest area
we continue to work with children's aid
society
with
other
youth youth and children service
providers to look at the best way we can
to have any of those children
removed prior to us entering into any
sort of engagement but again it is it is
a concern for us and we're taking every
step we can to mitigate that risk
the other the other uh risk was school
zones um we heard reports of of those
going to school zones and um it's very
difficult to monitor so many schools but
um
i just wanted to know how that is being
dealt with obviously this is
more complicated but um very important
and i know this is affecting the mental
health of many children who
were hearing about that not not just
parents
yeah absolutely so um as we've indicated
from the beginning of this demonstration
and protest that we we take any reports
that are around it extremely seriously
that includes the 15 reports of activity
in and around schools that we've
received to date most of those were
towards the end of last week we haven't
seen
an ongoing or increased activity in and
around school zones but i can tell you
each of those incidents is being
investigated and we've actually
increased our resources in and around
school zones
since we started to see an uptick in
those reports it's something we take
very seriously as well so we make sure
that we we have resources applied to
school zones
i appreciate it especially as the
downtown is emptied i am concerned
um that there will be a lot of uh
anyway it's another concern um in terms
of the integrated command center um
the the request previously was to have
1800 officers do we have 1800 officers
now working
uh so what i i'm sorry i didn't mean to
cut you no just yeah sorry just go ahead
yeah so what i can tell you is the our
integrated command center between our
the ops the rcmp and the opp has
proved to be extremely effective um
we've been able to get the resource
requests that we've we've been asking
for and we're able to pull together the
resources that we need to successfully
and safely end the occupation what i
will not be able to provide is any
detailed numbers of officers who we have
brought into the city to mount any sort
of
any sort of
activity that will help us
finally resolve this
okay thank you i i appreciate the fact
that uh there was a request so um but
you can't be specific on whether it was
totally committed to um because we were
all confused about how they were going
to be used but i'll leave it at that
thank you
counselor kits please
thank you
uh welcome interim chief bell it's not
easy to take the reigns mid-crisis so
thank you um we we know that there are
several
satellite encampments popping up across
the city including um two very close to
where i live actually in vars and
another one further down the street in
embryon
i've been in in constant communication
with the constable assigned to my area
he's been incredibly responsive and
accessible um
i've been conducting my own daily
surveillance it's remained relatively
small and i've connected with the the
russell township mayor but obviously the
majority of our resources are needed
downtown so i was hoping you could give
me an update on on how you're monitoring
these sites and i guess um what your
message would be for
nearby residents
yes so thank you for that question um we
are aware of the the activity in the
area that we're speaking about i'm i'm
very happy you're reporting good
communication with our community police
officers that's what they're there for
and to provide that sort of information
we we continue to work with our rcmp and
opp partners
as well as our
joint intelligence group to bring in
information about activities of those
areas and and all areas associated with
the demonstration as we look and as i
indicated in my remarks as we look to
finalize the occupation of our streets
it will include
finalizing all of the locations that
exist and have been contributing to the
illegal activities
okay thank you for that it's appreciated
um
we we carried counselor mckenny's motion
at the last special counsel meeting
requesting uh the rcmp to take over
policing the parliamentary precinct um
was was that request made refused if you
could give an update on the status of
that that would be helpful
um so yes thank you um
immediately
we had there was there was good debate
and good discussion around of that
motion at the time
i identified while that debate was
occurring that based on the current
police services act and the legislation
that exists around that the the motion
as as it was presented was not able to
be completed the rcmp will not come in
and take over authority or
responsibility for an area that is a
municipal police agency's responsibility
because they aren't allowed under the
police services act what we were able to
provide and indicate though is i did
understand the spirit of the motion and
the intention of the motion and through
all of our deployment models we've tried
to make sure that we did achieve the
spirit and intention of that motion so
that we could have our members in our
community where they best know our
residents and can help support them
okay um
my last question um
we know that obtaining resources from
other levels of government have been an
issue you mentioned in your opening
remarks that you're confident we have
the resources now um and and respond to
my colleague that we've had unparalleled
cooperation with other levels i guess my
question is is when did you see that
shift um what changed
so um
anytime you bring resources in it it
takes time but the opp and rcmp are both
big machines that take time to actually
identify the people to come with the
resources and skill sets that we need
and get them in onto the ground where
where we are
um where they're most needed we continue
to work and we have from very early days
with the rcmp and opp planning teams to
really refine and identify what exactly
were the resources we need and how do we
get them into our city that activity has
greatly ramped up over the last week and
particularly been refined and honed over
the last three or four days so that we
are seeing great cooperation and great
allocation of resources to our city so
it's hard to specifically point to a
time but i can tell you it's been
increasing and the cooperation and
partnership has been growing every day
okay that's good to hear thank you chief
bell
thanks mayor
thank you councillor councillor
brockington please
thank you mayor um thank you interim
chief for taking our questions
you said
you have a plan you have resources you
have the commitment
to getting the job done can you confirm
you do not seek or need any
additional resources
via city council to achieve your
objective you have what you need is that
correct
that is correct city council has
advocated for us from early days to to
get levels of cooperation from different
er different municipalities and
different levels of government and we
appreciate that and all of that work has
ultimately culminated in us being able
to develop a plan that we plan to
deliver to see a successful conclusion
of this
will you commit to council and the
people of ottawa that there will not be
an influx
of protesters or occupiers coming
downtown this weekend or will police
take action to ensure that does not
happen
i will commit to council that we have a
good well-resourced plan that we will
execute from now moving ahead to end the
occupation in this city
okay i appreciate that thank you thanks
semmer thank you councillor barkington
concierge super player
yes mr man and uh
hi uh
interim chief
i i want to call tell on the last
ask or comment by uh counselor
brockington so
chief many businesses and residents want
to know when they're going to get their
life back and um it is family day long
weekend
it is
you know it is an important time for us
as a community as a city
are we recommending that businesses open
uh this weekend along rideau street and
about hybrid market
so
where i'll start with that is where
what i indicated in my statement
we have great empathy for the impacts
that this illegal occupation has had on
our residents particularly in the in the
neighboring areas to where the red zone
is where the footprint of the
demonstration is and two
residents and businesses in market
center town
lower town area
we know how disruptive this has been we
know
how
taxing and how stressful and how it's
created feelings of unsafety and
insecurity we we absolutely know that
everything that we have done
to date and now moving ahead has been
intended to help restore that feeling of
safety and security that people have to
have with in their own neighborhood
where they work where they live
we now have developed a plan where we
are actually going to bring the
resources in a plan that i'm not able to
share timing of because of operational
uh requirements for us to be able to
execute it but i can let you know we are
as expeditiously as possible working on
trying to get this demonstration finally
concluded
with um with your reference earlier to
um it was counselor kitts's comment on
uh the work of the rcmp and and getting
i guess the spirit of that motion was
really bringing
ottawa police officers back into
our communities
and i've certainly seen officers back in
the community at closed intersections i
certainly do not debate that
but there continues to be extreme
concerns of public safety
uh and for for our businesses that have
chosen to open
and for residents walking uh in their
communities so
what what can you share with us on that
front uh i i know you are extremely
cautious on how you're describing your
plans of intervention and i i
i understand that
but we owe it to residents in the
meantime and through this process
to ensure that when they walk down the
street when they go to
particular uh commerce on our main
streets that they can do so safely and i
i've gone many times and i myself don't
feel safe so i i don't know if you're
aware of that i don't know if you if
there's particular
interventions by the ops to be more
present by foot uh outside of the
intersections of close streets in
neighborhoods
um so
i too have walked in those areas and and
i understand the concern of our
residents and of our business owners um
from
early days we identified a a uh surge
capacity within those neighborhoods to
specifically try and address those
feelings of
uns unsafety and insecurity
as we've received more resources over
the past week and particularly over the
past number of days i believe you would
have seen an increased presence of
officers within those areas we will
continue to have that increased presence
because the safety and security of our
residents
and the fact that they've lost it is the
number one concern for us so all of our
efforts are around ending this
occupation and making sure that people
feel safe where they live and work
certainly beyond the occupation we will
continue to
necessitate a strong by foot presence in
the in these areas to regain
public safety interest
i'd like to understand a bit better the
decision tree
of the
integrated command center
and i raise it as you and deputy chief
ferguson are aware
we continue to see
different
elements reported and when when they
make their way to the to that table
they're like an empty void we never get
information back or actions on the
ground so
i i've become a little um
a little delusion by the work of that
group not in the spirit of their ability
to intervene but in the intervene on the
occupation but intervene on those micro
information and you know for example we
had we had incidents at the bikers
church on the weekend we've had
um
uh vehicles park anywhere and everywhere
in residential area outside of the
occupation and it's making its way up to
the command center and
even local bylaw authorities are told
not to go in and act which
frustrates
community confidence in our ability to
enforce so i'd love to understand my
question is really the decision tree
what's the role what's your role what's
the role of ops and how can we make sure
that we don't lose sight of the
local interests and the local actions
that can
help rebuild uh rebuild and bring
community trust uh on during this
occupation
so i i am going to turn it over to
deputy chief ferguson to talk about the
decision tree that we've developed what
i can tell you is we've worked closely
with the opp and rcmp to develop a
command structure that has the common
goal of doing exactly what you say and
that is
remove the demonstrators and increase
safety and security of our residents in
in the city there is not a member who's
not a member of any police service who's
here that isn't actually directed
towards that mission i'll turn it over
to deputy chief ferguson and have her
explain
how our integrated command center and
command model is working
thank you and thank you counselor for
your question
um i know you and i have had some
conversations about this and it remains
a frustration for you
there's a couple of different
pieces there's our own internal command
center
which deals with a lot of the demands
for service
and so the issue at the bikers church
and that was fed into to that
stream
for them to be aware of it ahead of time
and to be able to assign
members to respond
and provide a presence
the the integrated command center that
we announced yesterday or spoke of in
the media yesterday is really
i'll try and make it as simple as
possible sort of a gold silver bronze if
you will and the gold level is
at the chief level the commissioner
level and that really is a very
strategic
approach to it uh keeping to the tenants
of what we're trying to achieve here uh
the silver level is is really the the
commanders uh in the seats who are
making the decision so plans are fed up
to
those commanders they review and assess
uh and are you know have
gone through several levels uh before it
gets to them uh and they are the
decision makers in that model and then
the bronze are really the people who are
separated out into their specific
subject matter experts so planning
logistics um you know operations
intelligence those pieces so there's
there's many different boxes that feed
up to that
that silver level where the the
decisions are made and uh
there's media involved there's there's
uh finance it's a really
well oiled machine
um so when when you get uh an incident
or something that is reported through
that
it should have gone it should go through
our operations piece and they assess it
against the risk and all of the other
priorities that they have going on and a
decision is made as to what resources to
apply to that so i hope that helps a
little bit
how do we just a
further clarification so how do we get a
local intervention not lost in the
bigger
uh the bigger planning efforts that's
that's how it feels certainly
over the last two weeks
i can appreciate that and i'm looking at
the numbers right now of the officers
who are deployed uh currently who
were sent out as of one o'clock this
afternoon and uh over 50 of our officers
are
on um i mean by ottawa police officers
are in
um in our our areas so uh we have you
know the community safety uh teams or
community engagement teams that is all
ottawa police officers we do have our
traffic unit who is out there who knows
the intersections who's aware of the
complaints and are receiving those and
responding to them
so we have done what we could
strategically to place members of the
rcmp and the opp who may not be familiar
with our city to static posts to traffic
posts to limiting
access
and egress to the
the red zone if you will and made the
best use of our people which is out in
the communities and doing what they can
okay my last question is
uh there was a plan motion in relation
to
an ask for the military and my interest
in that motion was specific to
understand
the need for equipment and logistics
most of us are born and raised in ottawa
and we can appreciate how canada day
over the years has changed where in most
recent years there's been checkpoints
with bags and so on and
that takes a lot of barricades it takes
a lot of
uh people resources to monitor the ins
and outs beyond that i think your no not
even if i don't have the details of your
plan
if if some of the rigs choose not to
move it is not local
oc transpo
uh towing that can manage the
you know the the tens
of rigs that would need to be moved so
i want to understand how serious of a
conversation we have had
uh with the province and the feds to
to present serious uh shortfalls on
equipment
such as
towing
to advance our local plans and i i'm not
looking to get into a particular tactic
that is not my intention here but my
intention is
it requires a number of plans you've
expressed earlier the issue of families
and kids you've expressed the issue of
resources
ultimately
you'll get to a point where you'll have
to make arrests and move people out
what's remaining as trucks and as you
know to get our locals life back it
requires some of those corridors to be
reopened
um so i'm interested to understand
what thoughts you have around uh that
sort of equip equipment need um
going forward
so um
every conversation we've had around this
has been exceptionally serious
um we continue
to work with all levels of government
to look and build all of the plans and
get all the logistical resources that
that we need to amount to successful
operation
we are working continuously to encourage
people to peacefully
leave the city leave the footprint right
now
but i can tell you all of the plans um
and i won't go into details of them but
all of the plans and all of the
considerations that are needed to
actually mount an operation to remove
uh people and equipment from the
downtown core have been developed by
some of the if not the best plan
planners in the country to make sure
that when we do begin this that it is
successful and ultimately ends this
protest
okay thank you uh thank you for uh your
intervention and responses
bill c jose councillor menard please
yeah i'm going to ask a quick question
and then i'm going to hand it off to
councillor mckenney who is currently on
the street in the community where
they've been um this entire time
um
and so
residents have been livid with with us
with uh with police with inaction and
about the contradictions they're hearing
so we're hearing competing messages all
the time
first we heard that this was peaceful
and then that there could be violence
and then when there was minimal
enforcement there was no physical
violence so people are wondering what
the truth is and then we keep hearing
that this is an unprecedented situation
we hear that over and over again but i
don't buy that
in 2019 some of the exact same
organizers did a very similar action
with a gofundme with a convoy of trucks
that went to the hill and parked there
with refueling of other people's trucks
with some of the exact same messages and
we also saw posts that this was coming
and that they were going to stay
long-term this time so why didn't we see
this coming initially properly prepare
the city and and why do we keep hearing
contradictions
so counselor bernard um i i share your
frustration i share your frustration
that these people are still in our city
that our streets are still overtaken so
i i completely understand
the frustration
anger upsetness that you're representing
on behalf of almost every citizen of
this city we share that frustration
we have continually been monitoring and
assessing the progress of this
demonstration that as you just
identified has changed in dynamic over
the past several weeks as it has
as it has arrived here as it has started
out as a protest and then occupied our
streets for the last two and a half
weeks
we will we will continue to manage and
monitor it we will continue to develop
our plans and look at how we implement
the plan that we're here to tell you
about today to ultimately end this
protest
i hope it happens as soon as possible
today would be a good day i'm going to
pass my time seed my time to counselor
mckinney well she's next anyways
counselor so counselor mckinney yeah
they are an expert
thank you um i am out here
on the street as you can see where
people live we're never [ __ ] leaving
yeah hi there
where people live and here we are
wednesday
wednesday
the evening we couldn't even have this
meeting early in the day
i have
i have not heard from anyone
whether it's the city whether it's
police anyone
what is the plan
that's the people
who live downtown who are under siege
will continue to be under siege
and there is
i don't know who is
hey bud i don't know who
is counting trucks
i don't know who is counting
uh what is happening here
but i can tell you
i can tell you
that
the street is not cleared our
residential area
is it is not clear
the smell of diesel fumes right now
is actually sickening
and i want to know
and i want to know specifically and i'm
going to ask the city
later on
what is the plan for this weekend
what is the plan so that we don't get
thousands of people
back on our streets
adding to this mayhem
and chaos
what are we doing how are you stopping
people from coming in
on the weekend to add to what is already
here
[Music]
so thank you for your question counselor
mckinney and um
again i i completely understand the
frustration that you're demonstrating
that you're articulating on behalf of of
your residents um we are actively
working as i indicated we're actively
working and have developed a plan that
is adequately and appropriately
resourced to ultimately end this
occupation that is what you will see us
roll out over the next coming days to
successfully have everyone removed from
our streets
but again
i'm not hearing
what is the plan
to ensure
that this mayhem and chaos
i love you i know you do we're not
leaving what is the plan so that this
mayhem and chaos is not added to
on the weekend
like what are we doing are we blocking
streets what are we doing are we
blocking uh off ramps we must be doing
something because we cannot have another
dangerous weekend
in our downtown
so councilman kenny i can't speak to the
specifics of the plan because it would
jeopardize its operational success but
what i can tell you is there's a number
of interventions that you will see that
you have already seen over the last 24
hours and you will continue to see over
the next day and coming days that will
achieve exactly what you're asking for
and will that
ensure that we don't get a surge of
new sympathizers to this occupation a
legal occupation on the weekend
that is absolutely part of our planning
and uh rollout
thank you mayor i'm going to have very
similar questions for city staff uh when
um
we go to that portion
because i have not so much has had
a message from city staff
we are tired we are fed up you can see
what people are living under here
it is not okay
and now we're playing political games
here today
and i've had it i pleaded with people
but now
now people in the downtown are angry and
they want action
i'll have many more questions later
thank you
thank you councillor english please
thank you mr mayor um and uh and chief
chief bell um i'm gonna call you chief
not acting on interim because right now
you are the chief
and and and i thank you for for stepping
up in a very difficult time to take on
that role
um
my question to you
is you've you've said several times that
you you there's a plan that's going to
unroll over the next couple of days you
can't give us the details i understand
why you don't want to give operational
details in public i understand that
but what i want to know is you were
appointed
yesterday
is this your plan
is this without giving us details is
this what you would have done is this
how you would have rolled it out
because you have to be invested in this
plan
the the the residents of the city of
lost faith that there is a plan that
there's a way forward
so i want to hear from you whether this
is a plan you are comfortable with a
plan that you would have proceeded with
in any event
or if this is a plan that you've
inherited
and you're you're tweaking it and you're
stuck with what you've got
or is this chief bell's plan to fix this
problem
so i'll start with my investment what
i'll say is i am absolutely invested to
work with our partners to end this
occupation that
know that know that i represent that on
behalf of every member of our police
service who is invested in ending this
occupation like i indicated earlier
we've brought in some of the best
planning minds in terms of these
operations from across the country i've
been fully briefed on the plan and i
have absolute confidence and support
that this is the plan that we will roll
out and we'll have success to end the
occupation of our streets
there is the investment of our police
service there's the investment of the
rcmp the opp and multiple other
municipal police services from ontario
and across canada that are working
towards the common goal to deliver this
plan to have a successful end to this
thank you for that chief and a quick um
uh follow-up um
more of a procedural practical question
i think you're hearing the frustration
from a lot of counselors that
we don't know what's going on
uh not whether we can direct you or not
but we don't know what's going on
because there's police services board
and there's council
and there's the ability of police
services board to go in camera
and to brief police service
board members
i don't know how much detail you go into
about plans or not
but
is the is there a mechanism
for counselors to be included in
in-camera briefings via the police
services board
uh so that would be a question that i
would turn over to david white and city
legal to actually answer
okay i'm fine to hear from mr white
mr mayor
um
the the determination as in the same way
that council and its committees
determine who it is prepared to invite
intuits in camera uh briefings um
depending on the matter that's to be
considered
um again that would be a question that
would be in the the purview of the
police services board
um
you know as to the the scope of
information of information of
operational information that
can be shared even with the police
services board
um
again even the board itself is not
entitled to
direct the chief with respect to
specific operational decisions or as you
know with the day-to-day
manager of the police service and so
that that may circumscribe even the
amount of operational information that
the police can or are prepared to share
um with respect to an ongoing operation
like this so
um
you know is is there a mechanism for it
um i think the mechanism may exist as to
whether that will provide members of
council with the degree of information
um and and again whether whether police
are comfortable sharing that degree of
information even in that context
is something that
i think you need to explore with the
board uh and presumably in conjunction
with the chief oh and thank you for that
clarification mr white and let me be
clear it was not my intent to suggest in
any way the council could direct the
police i think we all understand that's
not the case and it's not within our our
sphere of authority um just a quick
follow-up though mr white as you've gone
off camera
is um when you said that that would uh
have to go through the board
is that through the board in its
entirety or is that a decision that the
chair of the board would make or does
the board have to vote on whether or not
to include members of council uh in uh
in in-camera hearings
uh mr mayor in response the the the
board is ultimately as as his counsel
kind of the master of its procedure in
that regard um and and from my
perspective i'm not aware of anything in
their procedure biola that would that
would allow that decision to be made
solely for example by the chair
so if so would a board member have to
put forth that motion or would a council
member have to put forward the request
in writing how would that work
uh mr mayor given given that it's
something i'm not
aware has been done before that's that's
procedurally i think that's something we
need to explore uh with the board's
executive or uh yes executive director
okay thank you i just think it's
something that that that many many
council members would like the answer to
but
whether it's possible the how of it um
and procedurally that that could occur
so i'll leave that with you mr white and
and uh
and certainly you'll get back to council
with with what the answer is so thank
you for that i have nothing more mr
mayor
thank you counselor councillor please
hey chief i appreciate how accessible
that you've always been um to to me and
to us
and i appreciate how accessible you've
been over the last 24 hours given the
current situation so just a quick note
of thanks to you sir
i'm pleased to hear um of your plan and
to hear your commitments it really is a
ray of hope to those that have felt
under siege for weeks i'm concerned
that those who remain
may not be interested in leaving
peacefully built-up barriers uh make
operations such as this very difficult i
don't want specifics but do you have
mitigation measures in place to ensure
that any operation to end this keeps
nearby residents safe
thank you for the questions
it's a great question i can tell you the
safety and security of the members of
the public are paramount first and
foremost that is the safety of the
demonstrators and safety of our police
officers engaged in the operation so
every plan we have is is centered and
starts around public safety and the
safety of our community members
and bystanders as well people living in
adjacent buildings okay great
um
what's your message to the residents
that live nearby or in the middle of
this prior to any plan being executed or
ruled out
start with the empathy i i know how they
feel um i know how frustrated they are i
know that they haven't seen the action
that they need that they've deserved
over the last number of days over the
last number of weeks
what i can tell them is what what i
would tell them is there's an absolute
commitment from this leadership this
police service and our partners across
the country to end this so that they can
get their lives back so they can feel
safe in their homes and where they work
that would be my message
seeing some of the main organizers
posting that they are leaving
some some leaving to other provinces
pardon my dogs perhaps to save face and
avoid your enforcement efforts what can
i tell the residents um about those who
have broken the law here in the city and
are now trying to leave before any
arrests are made
so what i can let you know is one of the
um main pillars we started out from very
early days was the ability to collect
intelligence and evidence on those that
occupied here um if they pick up and
leave there still will be consequences
for the occupation and the damage
they've caused to our cities and the
residents of it the day this ends is not
the day the occupation in the street
ends is not the day this this
criminal process hta
fining process ends that will go on for
many months after this and people will
be held accountable for what they've
done to our city
thanks so chief so let's set some
expectations here so from start to
finish and we're not asking for timing
not looking for specifics what's the
kind of timeline that you're
anticipating from start to finish of uh
of your of your efforts
so i can't give for operational reasons
i can't give timelines i know i know
it's the question everyone wants to hear
i can't provide them because we have to
maintain operational security so that we
can have success in executing it what i
can tell you is it's not going to be a
quick it's not a quick turnaround this
is an operation that will take time over
a number of days to actually execute and
achieve
again my deep desire is people leave our
city those that are occupying our city
get in your vehicles and go home
we're starting to actually
increase pressure on them and encourage
them to leave our streets my absolute
hope is that they do that prior to us
having to intervene
thank you very much chief i've more to
say later um obviously but i want you to
be able to get back to doing uh your job
so thank friends but i really appreciate
you coming out today
all right thank you council of the loft
councillor gower please
chief um last week you had started the
police service had started doing daily
media updates i understand the last 24
hours have been
extraordinary is there a plan to restart
those or what is your plan for
media updates over the next few days
uh so we will have announcements as part
of the roll out of the culmination of
the occupation around our media strategy
and the media's availability to make
sure that we're providing the most
up-to-date and timely information on the
progress
okay
um i'll leave it there thank you for
your time uh and for answering questions
from council today
thank you councillor councillor king
please thank you your worship and uh
thank you interim uh chief bell for
providing uh this update i just had a
quick question um during the duration of
this meeting uh we saw uh an additional
further notice uh be issued to
demonstrators from ops i was just
wondering if you could
give us a little bit of detail in terms
of the difference of the document that
has just been issued now versus what has
been circulated
earlier this morning at different sites
as well as to where
these uh um
i guess notices have been uh circulated
uh throughout the city in terms of
location
um so in in
every location that there is
demonstrator occupation activities we
have actually engaged with them both
physically in terms of dialogue as well
as
media releases written materials as we
move ahead what you've seen is is a
stepped-up
approach through the day the latest the
latest release is
um is again an
escalation in our messaging to
protesters and demonstrators and i've
said it many times leaf it is time to go
home
we want you to peacefully exit our city
we will
facilitate that to get you back on the
road and go
go back to wherever you came from this
is going to end so we need you to leave
in a peaceful manner you're seeing our
messaging being
increasingly clear on the need for
people to exit our streets
thank you for that thank you man
we're uh coming up on um the chief's uh
time so i'd ask councillor al shanteria
that i think the chief has to be back
for a meeting that started five ten
minutes ago
counselor
uh thank you samir and thank you chief
my question actually to uh mr white as i
look at some of the history uh i believe
mr
white the board can
invite counsel for in-camera briefing
presumably they will follow the rules
and regulations the police board member
has to follow
so uh
if you know if there's an oath need to
be shared or you know to keep this in
camera i think it could be done because
i was looking at
at the justice uh morgan's report the
one about the g20 and there's a you know
there's an ability for the board
to be able to ask
the operation about their operational
plan not necessarily interfering their
plan but they can ask
about the plan and what the plan is and
i don't have to tell you about
modern support because you and i we we
study it to death at some point but
there is ability for council to join a
police board colleagues in the in-camera
meeting presumably that you know they
keep it confidential and the operational
it will be limited immigrant
yes mr mayor
thank you sir
council i'm just going to check with the
chief there's councillor menard has a
question uh do you have the time
so um mr mayor thank you for checking i
can take one final question but i do
have to go because our partners are
waiting okay councilman art i'll be
quick it's one question um there's
likely to be counter protests if no
action is taken we've already seen them
in some cases given the failure to act
so far
i'm wondering how you'll enforce
emergency act measures
if there's counter
protests
uh so um
again i understand the frustration of
our residents and we've been clear about
that throughout this that we absolutely
understand their their feelings as they
come into this
we would ask we we have a plan we have a
plan that's well resourced that will be
well executed we ask that there not be
counter protest so that we can properly
execute that plan and not divert
valuable resources away from what is
everyone's overall goal to remove this
occupation from our streets
okay how will you enforce uh there's
going to be counter protests in all
likelihood regardless of that so
how will you
enforce so we will will enforce the laws
um as as we have and as our plan is uh
throughout and moving ahead
okay i hope we side with the citizens
residents of ottawa on this one
thanks
okay thank you thank you very much uh
acting chief bell and your team um we
wish you uh
uh the very best a very challenging time
for our community and for our city and
our police service and
i know that uh you have
other obligations tonight and you've
been working very long hours so we very
much appreciate you spending some time
with us
thank you thank you very much mr mayor
thank you everyone